[Music]
much thank you very much for being here
so money I the the material the
tutorials online than my github
repository actually at the branch name
faded London 2017 so I think you're able
to check out book and clone the
repository if you have problems please
let me know I actually retailed a bit
the material I had to fit into ninety
minutes and I assume you already know
what a neural network is so I try to
give you the insight of actually what
carers can do it for you or when you
want to do some deep learning or neural
networks in particular but in any case
if you have dots on the questions feel
free to interrupt and I try to do to to
make this session more interactive as
possible so you will find a little many
exercises along the way so the very
first step is to clone this repository
with the command you see on the screen
please be sure that the branch by de
London is in the clone or command
because the master actually is a bit
different it's it was supposed to be a
three hour tutorial actually and I you
will find I know if it's too tiny maybe
I'll try to increase the font a bit okay
so I named this tutorial ten steps to
Karis my original idea was to have a
series of ten knock books in so for the
steps are to to guide you through the
different features of the Charis library
I'm I so I just II okay this is the
reference I'm actually running the in
case you have the material already on
your machine I'm running the preamble
here so the very first knock book I so
these are the goals for this session I
say introduce the main features of Karis
API learn how you may implement deep
neural networks using carers and
discover some internals of the net or
the framework and some peculiarities and
features these tremor cars so the
original plan was this one I slightly
changed it to try to fit into ninety
minutes actually I'm not sure if we can
do it but we'll try so it's more or less
the same stuff actually I removed some
part here so we you will not find any
example of variation or encoders in case
you know what it is or as a design your
networks but I will definitely happy to
talk about that anything after they need
to tell you if you want
ah so on I believe we will cover eight
of the steps in this tutorials but let's
see what would can do are the
requirements the padishah tutorial are
quite simple actually are I know that
you should be using anaconda peyten
on your machine I am managed to have to
our environments already are prepared
for you in the repository so in in the
list of files you will find two couple
of five here which is deep learning OSX
and deep learning dot yml these two are
the current environments you may use
respectively are using OSX or Linux
machine in case you have it so you can
just recreate the environment using
those two policy on anaconda if you want
but otherwise on the requirements are
quite simple so our Python and the set
of standard are scientific libraries so
9p site and um P supply and Maithili
pandas are and scikit-learn on Keros
will be the version 2 so the latest
version actually it's - oh poor the
latest version we'll be using it and our
tensorflow
um you will find informations in the
readme file so I can show you it may be
on I'm sorry
I will go online on the github if you
read it on if internet works hopefully
so actually the readme file you must
find some instructions somehow you may
sit up on piano tensorflow in case you
have GPU on your machines
okay here we go okay finally
or kind of switch to the find its Lunden
so in rip me here in the end actually
this should be updated in the this
outline is outdated sorry I just
realized in the readme file you may find
instructions in case you want to set up
the environment with anaconda in case
you have problems are installing our
tensor flow with GPU and indeed tensor
flow is not included in the replicas of
the environment because today's tensor
flow shapes were two different packages
that I believe you you already know in
case you have CPU or GPU support so you
have to install actually two different
packages which are named our tensor flow
for CPU or transfer flow GPU for the
GPUs version I'm okay and also you will
find instructions on how you may set up
piano okay I know probably seen the
other one I have to mix it so but it
should be quite easy to install it on
your machine
I believe anybody of you here has GPU
onion on either her machine I believe
but in case our Amir if you want support
okay yeah sure
yeah what do you mean by little because
yeah exactly the country's capability
yeah I believe tensorflow requires a
minimum of three as a version of
concrete capability and the compass
capability value that strictly depends
on the hardware so you have to see on
the specification on the spikes are you
yeah yeah I believe three is the minimum
yeah I and that's good question actually
especially because on this point out a
very important feature of Karis
as you will see in a very few minutes
I'm really looking forward start carers
are easier as a framework that sits on
top of piano in terms of flow okay so
the actual computation at the end of the
day will be performed by Tiana or sensor
flow depending on the background you
using okay so I the basically the
requirements are the ones of piano
tensorflow respectively okay that's it
so you will I actually ask you to are to
run the latest so the last cells in this
notebooks are to check if everything is
up and running when your environment so
these are the versions I mean I'm
currently going to use lead solution on
my Python numpy site by mass will sleep
with these versions so I could learn the
latest version and these three so
tensorflow 1 1 which is latest version
are stable version piano 0.9 as well and
care to all four versions but I believe
cares - will works as well on piano R
and sorry tensorflow 1.0 should work as
well okay so in case you don't time any
questions I will over thought can we
okay fine
so I the very first examples I decided
to include are induced obsession as the
multi-layer fully connected networks and
see how you can do it in on on using
cameras may ask you a question
previously how many of you already know
what in your network is great fantastic
that's was exactly what I was expecting
so fantastic so will not provide you any
details on it I will just go directly
through the code so the very
introduction of carriers is that carries
as a minimalist highly neural networks
library that as I said sits on top of
tensorflow in Tiano and are just to see
the features Kerris provide we will see
an example here I have gathereth are
these sets of data from a coggle
challenge are basically these very
simple toilet challenge under a simple
problem are we have the set of prop of
our products here so can you read from
the back okay so is it fine was too tiny
may I probably increase a bit this point
better okay so we have this set of
products on and are basically this
company the code of these problem is to
our identify they are the different
classes of products and we have a data
sets of 93 features for each product for
more than 200,000 features the objective
is to build a predictive model which is
able to distinguish on between our main
products and categories
so it's row of our data set will
correspond to a single product and we
have 93 different new micro features you
can grab the data from the coggle our
data sets dig the website but actually
you already have the data into the data
folder Bureau on repository so it's a
data's lash goggle auto group is the
data folder
so we will try to face this problem
using very simple and stupid model which
is the logistic regression will start
very simple and so this is the plan so
on we actually load the data we we apply
in the second cell here are quite
standard operations on the data set okay
we pre-process the data and we basically
if you take a look at the function here
pre-process the data it's just that
standard scaling of the features no more
than that on and we also pre-process the
labels to make the so-called one hot
encoding are okay then we see we checked
the different labels we have so as I
said we have ten different classes now
probably didn't say that so we have ten
different classes I know sorry nine
different classes and as you see white
rain has been one hot encoded do you
know what an odd encoding it okay point
so on the plan for this tutorial sorry
for this not book is to show how you
make tackle this problem using piano
okay for a simple are tensorflow then
and so how the code changes and how you
can do the same stuff basically using
our carers okay so I will not go very
much into the details of this ah so this
is the idea I don't know if you're
familiar with our piano on syntax so
basically what you have to do is to
define our matrix and vectors here and
we also define shared variables okay
that will basically are accept our
values so the ry and B will be the
learned parameters of the model of the
logistic regression and we will then
construct the piano expression graph
here do you know what that what's the
computational model behind piano you
know it's okay so very quickly on both
the a no intensive flow
are based on our symbolic computational
models okay so this means that actually
you're defining what is called
placeholder from some framework so you
actually define the placeholders you're
not feeding into these objects any data
yet until you basically run the
compilation in fact if you import piano
for the first time it seems to do some
work because the import is not very
reactive in the very first at the very
beginning okay and that's because it's
basically compiling on your machine
piano tends to close out differences
actually they're not actually the same
thing and but we may assume that they
are the same for this tutorial but
they're very differences in the
architecture and the the are general
design they have especially because
tensorflow piano was born definitely
before the deep learning era and on the
other hand tensorflow is being designed
which are distributed our computation in
mind from the very from the very
beginning and so that's that's why they
they turned up to be sort of competitors
nowadays and caris our stands basically
on top or in the middle depending on
what you fancy the most so I I will not
go very into too much into these are
example details of these examples and so
I'm actually implementing here using
Theano on syntax are the logistic
regression and in particular these are
the are functions I'm actually
implementing the updates and what piano
tensorflow provides you out of the box
is the computation of the gradients okay
so that's why you want to use it instead
of implementing all these stuff in PU
Python because you already have all the
functions and the graded competition
already they're out of the box ok so you
may see that this is a quite are not
very intuitive since
to do it and it's very low level I would
say it's very on and you have to
implement every each step of your
algorithm okay so we are basically
implementing the our training phase here
for the logistic regression another
thing I actually miss to say is that our
we are implementing the logistic
regression as our neural network you
need because they're basically say if
you think of it they're a logistic
regression may be implemented as a
neural network with our linear
activation
oh sorry our sigmoid activation function
okay with just one layer okay that's
what I'm actually doing here okay so
it's it's just details and so this is
just to show you what is the syntax you
have to learn if you want to learn piano
and on the other end you will see
example on using dancer flow so
tensorflow is a bit different on some
sense but the the feeling of the API is
more or less the same you had with our
piano because you always have to define
plays others here okay and then you have
on to define variables here but the very
important thing is that when you're
actually creating these objects here so
here we're creating a variable and are
initialized with a set of zeros with
these dimensions what we are actually
creating here our tensor objects not
actually not real object a when our
meaning here is that are these objects
are just placeholders that when you
receive the data when you you're
basically performing the the training
session
okay the training look and you will see
in a bit how you can do it in fact on
the on if you basically okay let me try
to run this cells okay okay sorry
I probably this because I
and I didn't execute it anything here so
on let me lower the data okay fine so
let me skip the owner here and okay
if I want to print X okay this is the
tensor object there's no value in it
okay so basically this is as its it as
it is a placeholder an object that are
wasteful values to be fed in okay I the
all these other arm syntax here so scope
it's just to exploit on very particular
tensor terms abode sorry tensor flow
feature which is the tensor board but I
will show you what is minute what's the
result of this so we're actually
defining two variables here we define
the activation which is softmax so the
classification then we're defining the
loss we want to optimize
so the categorical cross entropy in this
in this case are and then we define the
optimization process which is the
stochastic we descend all these
libraries and piano intensive flow as
well provide you objects already
out-of-the-box ready to be used so you
don't have to implement anything in view
piping so then we just are creating the
accuracy metrics and we finally want to
arm we want to run this issue and to do
it we have actually to create the
session object okay and we then
initialize all the variables we have
defined okay and then we run during this
session this we're actually using very
[Music]
particular Python syntax which is the
context manager so it's very pythonic
this one
we're running during this session we are
fetching are these operations okay and
we
providing values here so we are feeding
the actual value is the actual data into
the placeholders during the session okay
this is the way you have to use our
tensor flow and providing data during
the learning place so if you run it
actually okay you have the accuracy
changing this is the actually the
accuracy trend for all the air books we
have okay and finally prediction if you
run this cell here okay I can show you
what's happening and this is another
very interesting feature of tensor flow
so I actually creating mold and stuff
here okay
I finally running this one okay and then
if you go to your lock lost to the port
600 6 you will see what is called the
tencel board which is another nice
feature tend to flow provides you if
you're lucky enough you will see
something okay fine so all that very
strange our syntax so all the Scopes
I've defined it was actually to store
the different results we had during the
computation and so tensorflow ships with
these nice feature which is the tensor
board okay you will see are the are
different
trying different trends years through
the mean of the of the bias and weights
are of the cost function and accuracy
here and finally we also have an input
of the bucket we have defined okay we
we're actually we've been actually
defining these models using tensor flow
and this gives you the idea and what's
actually the competition our model
behind them supply which is based on
graph okay so it's it's quite a bit
complicated I I have removed a lot of
details
when you explained u2e to you but you
have to think of it as a graph of a
series of nodes that corresponds to
these four operations and the edges
between the operations are maybe the
data actually the dependency between
different operations okay and so the
tensorflow compiles your code into these
graphs and then executes this graph and
the nice feature it does is that you
make it you can also be able to
distribute this competition so the
different parts of this gruff may be
distributed among different hard work on
the single machine or even on different
machines so it does flow is a nice
nicely nice library with lots of
features but you're always stuck with
this kind of syntax of this pythonic
syntax which is of course by tonic but
it's definitely row level okay you have
to implement a lot of stuff here even
they are training look so for each
effort you up to feed the data one bets
at a time actually we are doing full
batch in case you know what this but you
in case we want to do but or learning we
have to implement a double loop so one
for each air pocket then one for each
batch and that has to be implemented in
Python because there's nothing provided
for that out of the box of course and so
we do it so we have the example of using
carers so actually the same model we
already implemented in Theano in terms
of flow will be reduced in these five
lines of codes okay got the main feature
of carers so carrots
basically provide you a pythonic
interface on top of the animal
tensorflow okay that gives you the
ability to create neural networks in a
very pythonic way in a very intuitive
way so the API have been built with our
clearness and comprehensible Khan
understandability okay in mind sorry on
okay and so I on also are apart from the
availability of the different layers
okay as you can see we have imported the
sequential object that gives you the
idea that basically we're building our
feed-forward Network okay
so it's a series of layers and so it's a
sequence of layers and so a sequential
object okay where we can hard different
layers in this case we've imported the
dense and the activation objects are
from these Kerris layers the dense layer
is of course the fully connected layer
okay so it's dense and the activations
are sort of layer actually it's not a
proper layer but in Karis are terms
isn't is a layer object and we've just
set up this network very simply using
the sequential object okay so we had
just add the dense layer as the first
layer defining the number of units so
the number of classes we have because
we're implementing I remind you the
logistic regression we specified the
sigmoid activation function in finally
the softmax
our activation for the last decision
layer and as you can see we've
specifying already provided functions
using strings so we are not defining any
tricky and straight object we're just
providing parameters and the object
already are passed and provided for you
by carers and the last two steps the
most important ones are the first one is
compiled and this gives you the idea
that piano and terms of flow require a
compilation step before actually running
the code and this compile method is the
method that are basically does the job
so creates they translate the Python
object defined in carers into the
specific back-end you're actually using
so the anno tensorflow so far and
finally we have the feet method which is
the method we want to use to start
learning process okay already provided
for you
so if you run this code you basically
you will
something like this one so you see the
different depth box running and in these
case we actually have just the loss
specified so we see the trends of the
loss here and in the end you will see
that the feed function will return these
object this carers callbacks history
object we'll see in a bit
what's it so it's quite impressive I
would say any questions so far
anyone yes yes exactly exactly slip yeah
sure yeah yeah exactly
yeah oh yeah sorry so actually the
question was that we are we've been
using the add method to art of the
sequential object to our add different
layers to the network was it right yeah
okay great so yeah exactly exactly
exactly
no actually the compile step is what is
actually creating graph in terms of flow
on piano
if you want the tensors you just
basically navigate the object from
cara's you can access the app the
tensors directly okay I will show you
that a later on and I don't think I just
to mention once you mention is that um
ah maybe you already notice it but if
you basically cut these file so in your
home directory this works on Linux and
OS X and winners the path is a bit
different but you in your home directory
after you installed a Karass you should
have these file here okay which is our
Kara's slash Kira's dot Jason
uh-huh
stuck some region sorry I don't know one
okay but anyway these five are these
file contains actually the main
configurations for carers and in news
files you basically specify which what
is the back end you want to use by
default is piano are the many reasons
but if you just want to use stents or
flows the back end you have just to
switch these directive in the caches
entire okay so that's it if you want to
use piano the the important feature of
this is that you basically do not change
any single line of your code when you
want to switch the back end because all
the job is made by the anger by carers
of course okay that's it okay so a very
on quick of view of the parameters of
the dense layer so you are the first
parameter you have to specify the units
you want okay and then the activation
are in case you ones are an activation
for the for these layer if you want to
use the buyers and a serious of
parameters for regularization and for
initialization
by default the ternary initializer is
the garage uniform so it's a uniform
distribution of weights for the for the
W and zeros for the bias by default our
other core layer okay or the cold layer
you may have flattened reshape permute
many operations you may apply the
definition is quite straightforward so
please take a look and in Karis you may
actually provide
networks covering basically all the
three main groups depicted in this
picture in this picture so feed-forward
network and in particular convolutional
network a require new and network and
also auto encoder for the in supervised
part
we'll try to show you example thought
problems the activation is actually as I
said our core layer in terms of our
carers API semantically it's not a
properly a proper layer actually it's
just an activation function but you may
encode it as a layer in the network and
also in Karis you have are a set of
optimal optimizers ready for you for
different optimizations so we've been
using the stochastic or InDesign which
is the default one I believe but you may
have many are for instance a degrade ADA
delta-ms prop many of them I mean you
and of course you may also define your
own are optimizing in case you will have
a very specific optimization function
you want to optimize so you want to R be
defining a bit these are challenge data
this or problem ok this is just the the
occasion showing on to mention a couple
of very nice features here so first of
all on the model object you have this
method which is the summary and the
summaries are chance themself to be very
useful in many cases because it provides
you a summary of your network okay in
these summary you see the the name of
each layer you have and the output shape
which is definitely important and the
number of parameters you have so
especially with these very simple and
stupid network we just have 846
parameters to optimize okay our answer
of them are non trainable so all of them
are trainable so then we just are do the
design thing a bit these exercise we
just trained are we just trained and a
split the data so we have an extraneous
validation step sets and we provide
these two sets separately in the feed
map model ok so we are actually are
specifying additional parameters to the
feet method here in this example and try
to separate it so maybe maybe written
best readable ah so we provide explain
oops
why train at the data and acts well why
validation data we specified the number
of epochs we want okay
automatically the verbosity here level
of velocity and moreover the size of the
batch in case you want to do batch
learning and finally a couple of
callbacks and this is quite useful
basically Kara's provides you the
ability to inject callbacks are objects
imported directly from Kara's API so
from Charis callbacks we import early
stopping in model checkpoint very
intuitively the early stopping is the is
the most useful one here the early
stopping is a callbacks that allows you
to specify a number of on epochs are you
want to control and the specific
function you want to or to be monitored
during the learning phase so that are
when in this particular case after two
consecutive steps during the learning
phase the validation loss does not
change basically the learning stops
without without going on for all the box
that's particularly useful okay
especially to avoid the learning rate to
diverge during the learning process and
the model checkpoint basically stores
for you to magically the bath bottle
found during block ve different epochs
okay so we've just our increased in this
particular example the early stopping
does not is not very useful because all
the fifty-eight box have been performed
but you're definitely feel free to
change the value of each box and see if
something changes okay so our with these
very few lines of Gerrits we just
defined a very single layer network so
what happens if you want to add more
layers inside this network and so we
want to finally implement the
multi-layer fully connected Network
just a quick iron sort of note about the
notation sometimes multi-layer networks
and multi-layer perceptron I considered
synonymous actually are as far as I know
the monthly episode prime is just a
multi-layer network we just see one
single even layer in in the middle okay
when you basically have more than one
leading layer in the network you're
allowed to call the network a deep
network okay
that's it and so the question is how
hard can it be to build a multi-layer a
monthly a fully connected Network
precarious and the answer is basically
it's basically the same stuff just add
more layers okay and so in this case
we're actually we're actually just
adding one single layer we're adding one
dense layer of 100 mirrors in it okay so
the units please keep in mind that the
very first layer of the network has to
unsolder
must specify the input shape okay so you
have always to specify the input shape
in the very first layer and this
particular case we have just vectors of
these dimensions okay really defined
previously and so if we print the
natural topology here we have just one
dense layer more than the previous
example okay so here we have one dense
layer and then another one and find the
softmax activation function here and so
definitely the number of parameters have
been increased definitely why so so much
and so again the the code is quite the
same so we just fit again the model okay
we just pursue I just specify 20 box
here that's basically the same thing
okay so now it's your-turn
are trying to play bit with a Keres api
and try to add even additional layer
here and try to run and are see if
everything is up and running
okay would you know okay
oops I totally public
okay networks
probably one thing you want to do here
is to add a summary before the fit okay
so it probably something like modal dots
summary may be useful and then the fit
here
any questions in the meantime
yeah exactly
yeah it's called Leia in Karis and
syntaxin curse API in terms of objects
but it's actually the activation
function yeah yeah probably yes but you
can actually plug the activation to make
it more intuitive and more simple in
terms of readability and as a parameter
of the of the of the layer actually if
you see you should take a look at the
API of the dense layer for instance okay
there is a parameter here which is the
activation okay and as you can see here
these parameter may be the name of the
activation function to use so a string
okay or alternatively an element-wise
the other function if you don't specify
anything your activation is applied to
it's the linear activation okay so in
case you're using a standard activation
you may just provide it as a string in
the definition of layer and that's it is
basically things up watching what you
cannot do is basically the last layer
should be in activation softmax I
believe yeah yeah sure yes
like functions including immigration
function what is there any particular
advantage of oh yeah it's it's strongly
depends on the problem you have attend
and the date you want Christine so as
we'll see in next notebook swing when
you do our convolutional networks for
instance it's very rare that you want to
use sigmoid functions and it's better to
use for instance really function because
the real function is in all linear
function and when you do convolutions
you basically do linear operations
because the convolution is indeed an
operation and so you want to add
non-linearity in the end and the real
function has been proved to have lots of
properties for this on the other hand
when you do our recursive unit networks
most of the time in the gate into the
internal gates you are you use I
provoked tangent as the functions but
this strongly depends on the problem you
have and today too you have you have to
know a bit the data you want yeah yeah I
know that that's the matter of deep
networks on my filling but it is that
deep neural networks are a very are
effective once you've found your setting
okay and that's the difference with
classical machine learning I believe so
we with classical machine learning you
turned up to half on a model okay which
works in most of the cases are nice but
with dim networks you may have performed
that normal if you find exactly that
settings you need otherwise you end up
in a very mess of parameters and
microphones as you
nice that's problem deep networks
actually we have lots of IP from tests
you optimize apart from the parameters
that is the the matter of deep networks
deep learning is machine learning in the
end yeah it's a same stuff there's
nothing different what what changes it
actually the second model see you apply
to the problems because it Weaver
there's no free lunch theorem that's
definitely yeah okay in case you don't
have any other question I will move
ahead was it simple to to play with it
okay nice very good any Dobbs so far any
problem point it was pretty simple
okay so there's an addendum here which
is the Karis back-end it is I will go
through very quickly this is something I
just wanted to show you which is
something inside Karis actually so
carers provides you this arm model which
is called the backend okay and if you
see the internals of Karis actually the
are the Charis model the module sorry
it's what it's in the middle between the
pythonic API of Karis and the actual
back-end okay so you have to think of it
has a middle layer between the our code
of the sequential object for instance
and the actual back end which is
tensorflow or the-- a node so far so on
and you can use it for your own code so
you may import the Charis backend and
you may actually try to implement the
same code we already provided r2 on to
solve the the same problem here through
the same set
of data so these are the syntax of the
Charis back-end it's okay if the Charis
back-end and we in the Karis back-end we
can also define placeholders and
variables just like we can do in tensor
flow okay the very difference with this
one with this code that when you use the
careth back-end you're you're basically
guaranteed that this code will run on
both the frameworks both the the
backends okay again without changing any
single line of code okay so we're
actually using we are actually defining
code here which is not very strict to
any single back-end we're not using any
particular feature if it's a matter of
carers to translate these instructions
through the specific syntax of the
backend okay but the feeling is that
you're basically doing our very low
level implementation here so you have
the K dot k categorical cross-entropy
k soft marks we're not back into the
python api it's more like tensorflow ish
api okay something like that so you can
go through these are example it as you
can see basically if the feeling is that
we're implementing intensive flow but
actually we're not we're implementing
use the care of spec end and so if I
switch the backend so actually it was
just one request for these notebook if
you if you run the previous cells okay
and then you switch the backend in the
care stop chasing file sorry in the
cascading file and then you restart
there's not look and yuri execute the
instructions that should work actually
works the same way without changing any
single line okay that's the power of
cares indeed
I this the speeches are this feature
quite upsetting I believe because this
saves you a lot of time especially ah
when you have to do let me say very
general and not very narrow or deep
learning code okay when I say narrow
they mean very specific and very highly
optimized code are in the sense that you
want to actually trick and you want to
implement very specific non-standard
functions okay and when you want to do
it at the end of the day it turns out to
be very effective to use carers
especially because the two different
backends
I mean piano or tensorflow have
differences in the way they allocate the
memory on the GPU for instance okay
that's not a matter that you have to
face sooner or later when you do these
kind of things for real on the GPU okay
and they have I it was these was true
especially a few months ago that they
had very different behaviors Amit and it
was very nice to have that very simple
feature to switch the back end to see if
the memory allocation worked well using
thermo photography I know without
changing any single line of code it's
just a matter of changing the fire
yes/no it really depends okay but in my
case I end up using it because I that
time I was using tensorflow that version
of tensorflow had problems in allocating
memory on the on the GPU I was
processing with a very deep network lots
of images okay and I switched through
theano because at that time it was more
efficient in another particular hardware
I had and that was it
so I just changed the back end and I was
done in one single second I was
that's very simple okay okay so I I
would skip this exercise if you don't
mind
actually I these exercise are ask you to
use the Karis back-end implementing the
linear regression not the logistic
regression design so it's a slightly
different example
um but you should have the solutions
okay in your our repository I didn't
remove it so actually I can show you
then
ah sorry ah why not
should be there
it
I don't know life is just complaining
okay okay sorry it was a typo I believe
are okay so we're defining the model and
loss here and we're defining the art
gradients and the updates it feels like
implementing in theano intensive flow
but I complete I promise this works with
both the on the back end okay but it's
still Karis code and so again we have to
implement the training on the training
loop here and we want to plot the
history again it's just the same stuff
okay
so I low the solutions for you it's
basically the same code already
presented previously for the logistic
regression here so a final note if you
switch the back end please go out go
back to tensorflow because before moving
on because it may be useful in some next
on knock books okay so any questions huh
yes please
I'm sorry when you do sorry I cannot
hear very well I I do yeah sorry
well I II I read oh no in the sense that
I do not have any specific experience
that before it I I know that tensorflow
has some support with a dupe but I can
not say more than that so I'm sorry
sorry any other question yeah please
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah so on it
displays yeah good question and I asked
for this knock book this was basically
to give you the idea that the carers
back-end exists and it's there most of
the time you end up using the previous
version so the sequential object okay
sometimes may be useful in case you want
to implement custom functions okay
so in case you want to implement your
own optimizer or you want to implement
your own custom layers you end up using
these back-end functions because for
instance when you have to implement the
learning of a layer you have to use the
carers back-end functions between
tensors because these functions have
been already defined to operate between
sensors and so when you want to do the
mean for instance okay imagine you'll
want to define a custom layer that's has
to basically average the values of sets
of neurons okay to prove a sort of
pooling okay you want to implement a
sort of pooling layer down sampling
layer okay when you want to do the mean
between the the develops of the values
of the neurons you have to use the mean
function to find the Charis back-end
that's it okay
it's customary yes yes yes but in case
you you prefer these sort of flavor okay
to implement the newer network you can
do it okay
it is not our highly suggested because
Chara's provides you a lots of code
already for you okay so it's basically
reinventing the wheel sometimes but in
case you want to do very specific things
that's the module you have to use and if
you take a look at the internals okay
these code is what is actually use it in
the Karis code when it has to translate
the operations to real back-end running
okay so keep these in mind
caris is not doing any operations on the
GPU on its own it's just delegating the
operations to the specific back-end okay
so it sits on top of it okay may move on
yeah sure
okay that's nice question indeed a swap
torch I know it in very details I know
just that fighter which has been
released but is very recently I think a
few weeks ago it was just torched so it
was lower and no bitin and I probably
think that fighters just support Python
- yet I don't know anyway it's not a
matter
as for the AMEX net there are some
rumors that says that there's an MX net
back end to be released for carers okay
for sure this are there is the an
implementation going for a back Karis
back end for the CMG Kay a framework
which is the Microsoft deep learning
framework and they are implementing us
are Karis back and for it I'm athletics
net and pop I thought I didn't know
anything I cannot properly answer the
question because I don't really know the
features of phyto so I don't know the
mismatch I've been told that my torch is
better when you want to do on a yeah in
some way yeah in there I don't really
know the very detail so I cannot be more
precise I'm sorry okay
or so the okay the the next notebook is
just to introduce the data set probably
you already know this data set right so
I will not spend so much something much
time on it
the amnestic sets also known from the
psych and learn guys as the digits data
set I did you know visit set anybody
doesn't okay fine okay so it's very i
heavily use data set even in research
papers and so the the objective is to
recognize handwritten digits so the so
in this data set we have a set of 60,000
our samples and 1,000 10,000 test set a
test images sorry on 28 times 28 the
dimensions and Karis eyes just like
psychic zone provides this data sets on
model module that includes the Emma
state set for you so you have just to
import and miss from Cal State sets and
load the data okay these will our
download for you today chapter magically
in your home folder in case you don't
have it in particularly the dot carers
folder flash data sets okay and okay so
these are not book will ask you to play
a bit with these state set just to to to
know are what type of data we are
actually handling and what are the
features and the the samples were you're
actually dealing with okay do you want
to play a bit with oh I just move out
you choose right it's fine it's very
simple this set okay so
okay so let's see what we can do for it
okay nice
okay so we try to implement in this
notebook are fully connected layer
feed-forward network are on the on this
data and on digits data this is a sort
of recap actually the fully connected
layer has the sigmoid activation
function in each Eden layer okay and we
also had some additional type of sort of
layers in this network just to see
differences we will keep the definition
of models using the sequential objects
okay
and so our and then we introduce a new
on activation function which is the Riu
function okay I believe most of you
already knew what it is so the really
function is this function here it's the
maximum between zero and the actual
value so it basically drops out any
negative value here and it's it's as a
serious of mathematical properties that
are been proved to be very effective
concretely in real problems okay
ah and these note says that keep in mind
that this function is heavily used on in
C n n so in convolutional neural
networks okay so the very first exercise
I would kindly ask you to do is to
implement this network so it's a fully
connected layer with 512 events plus a
real function at the activation and then
repeat these are twice so two times and
then are fully connect lay in the end
with the number of classes plus the
softmax
for the activation okay actually there's
this code down here sorry I forgot to
delete it
I'm sorry so this is actually the
solution so we'll go ahead
it's quite simply in any way to me it's
just like sequential object again okay I
please note the different our imports I
had so we import from models the
sequential object and then from the
layers Co we import dents actually drop
offs not yet it's it will be used in the
next series of cells and from the
optimizer we import this to category
descent so in this case they the only
thing I would like to point out from
this example is that differently from
previous examples I'm actually plugging
inside the compilation a Python object
and the optimizer instead of a string
here okay and this means that these
object may be configured and you want to
do this in case you want to tune the
default parameter that's the only case
you have for instance when I'm using
these are so from carers oh sorry let me
you execute it
okay this has to be executed as well
okay so I if I want to see the
documentation of this de category
descent okay so you will see that the
parameters are the learning rate which
is our 10 to the minus 2 by default the
momentum which is zero the DK which is
zero by default and the Nesterov
optimization R which is a momentum which
is the force by default
okay so if I'm basically creating this
object here I'm passing these SGD string
I'm actually doing the same thing but in
the case I want to tune the learning
rate for instance I can actually just do
this one SGD learning rate equals two
I know 10 to the minus 10 to the minus 3
okay so I'm plugging the optimum
optimizer object with the specific
parameter okay and as I said previously
most of the time you end up optimizing
the I per parameter you have in your
networks and we will see there is a
specific nut book for it and another new
thing I we are doing here we're actually
plugging the matrix we want to optimize
during the learning rate the sorry the
learning phase and in this case it's the
accuracy okay so after the calculation
has been done okay we prepare the data
and in particular our so if we load the
data okay let me just execute this three
lines here we didn't we skip that from
the previous notebook that's why you
don't know it okay so we know that we
load the data and if we take a look at a
shape of these data okay we have 60,000
on samples as we expected of these
dimension 28 by a times 28 by the very
first layer of our model okay is
extract a limpid shape which is 784 okay
so we have to yeah an important thing to
notice here the number of units is
specify as the first parameter of the
layer is the output units okay it's what
you expect in output
okay exactly is that fine - you okay
so on so we expect these dimension in
output in input sorry and so we have to
reshape the data to fit into the network
and so we do the reshape here which is
28 times 28 fine and then we specify the
data floating point numbers actually if
you're using GPU are there's another
trick I and I can share with you are
it's not the trick shot actually it's a
sort of lesson learned from the
experience if you if you're dealing with
integers data which is not the case of
course but actually it is the case
because we are we have our grayscale
images so from 0 to 20 255 if you're
running this code on a GPU there's no
way the GPU can use the integer data by
default actually especially I think
that's a flow does not operate as no
colonel it calls it so no operation for
integers on the GPU okay so you have to
convert it as floating-point numbers
okay so that's why I'm using these has
type here and then we okay we put
everything on a great girl for to be
sure okay
and finally we convert our set of
classes using the one hot encoding and
this function to categorical has been
imported by the NP utils mod module from
Charis as well okay so we're using
carries code here
for Karis code okay then we are again
are we strain and test split the data
okay to create the training and
evaluation set okay so we have these
shape as we expect it we print these
image I'm sorry I missed the import I'm
so sorry I missed this one okay so we're
printing this image and to cross-check
we see the corresponding class in the
Epsom trained in white rain sorry in the
Wine Train so it's one corresponding to
the fight which is what we expected and
we print another one from this track
from the violation which should be four
and so the one hot encoding puts the are
hot bit to the for class which is fine
okay then so we fit our model here it's
just two e box but feel free to increase
number of box you want we provide the
best size and we provided validation
data here okay and we store this time
the result of the fits method into an
object which is called Network history
and reason why we need to do it is
because our this object is actually our
Karis callback automatically provided
for you that basically thought all the
history of the metrics during the feet
our process okay so this is actually a
sort of what we did manually intensive
flew in the very first example we did
plugging that summary our operations
okay we plug that manually into the
tensile flow this is a sort of that
particular feature to be honnest there
is another callback in Karis which is
the pencil board and callback I didn't
have time to too
that example into these serious and not
books but actually if you're using
tensor flow at the back end you can plug
another callback in the feed method
which is the tensor board callback and
so care is it automatically integrated
with the tensor bode which is a tensor
flow our feature okay so you can you can
see on the history of your feet process
inside the 10 support so we saw these
natural history here because we want to
plot some information from the feet
process and in particular we'll want to
see the we want to compare which is
quite usually it's quite the case most
of the time we want to compare the loss
of the training and validation as well
as the accuracy on the training and the
volition set and so with it using this
network history so if you in case you're
wondering how these network history has
these two are metrics here it is because
the loss metric is by default and the
curacy is because we add that during the
compile of the amount of the model here
so we add these metrics into into the
computation and so the these three now
stores information about these metrics
as well and you can we can had series of
metrics in case you have and
automatically the the metrics have been
split in two because in the fit we
provided also validation data so we have
training in addition metrics and so we
see the metrics here so the loss after
just two epochs okay so we have these
loss here and these are accuracy so the
training and validation so we reached on
almost eighty eight percent violation
accuracy with just two epochs are it
would be nice to see if we increasing
number of epochs
we end up - I'm okay
so on my suggestion now is try to
replicate that code so that you can are
memorize it a bit and increase the
number of epochs
there's unimportant things are to notice
now if you just copy and paste the code
okay without compiler compiling it again
okay the thing is that you're basically
reusing the same model again
okay I try to be clear here so if we do
it this so my question was try to
increase the number of your box okay
what you can do is just like sorry what
you can do is just like these so I just
copied these line and fine fine it works
trust me or not it works okay so I just
I don't I just took ten and it goes and
goes okay
the things are the thing I'm actually
doing here I'm actually retraining the
same network okay so the starting point
of the weights here is not the random
white as you may expect is just the
latest weights you had in the previous
step okay to create the network model
network from scratch you have to recall
the compile again okay when you do the
compile the network has been recreated
from scratch you see so yeah
I GP you actually I'm sorry that's why I
you can run it on the CPU sometimes yeah
having a jiff you may be a handy but
it's not required in all every time ok
you can actually do the same on CPU and
sometimes it ends up to be even more
efficient on on the CPU especially when
you have lots of data moving from the
run to the realm of the GPU back and
forth okay
but these frameworks are guaranteed to
work on CPU as well so having G view is
just to make things go faster no more
than duct that's it and that's why
actually I was pointing here this if
your hardware allows do because having
more airbox of course requires more
competition yeah sure
just compiled ibly yeah yeah exactly
yeah so I would just like do this okay
so the idea is try to do this
okay so sorry where is it uh-huh okay I
got it okay
anyway I recreate the model from scratch
I run with Yui box here okay so I got
these validation loss violation accuracy
or okay I run it with 2e box again okay
as you can see the accuracy is
increasing okay I'm actually running
again in other 2d box and may actually
increasing it because the weights are
read there if I just plug it these which
is the compile here it works because the
model object is has been ready defined
in Python actually okay so that's it
it works yeah
I'm yeah you can actually take a look at
the weights inside and see if something
changes I will show you in a bit
ah I will just like to introduce a new
layer which is a drop out layer I drop a
layer it's a very simple layer that
turns out to be very handy in many cases
so it is used to avoid overfitting
especially in convolutional networks so
if you want to apply the drop the idea
behind the droplet APIs is very simple
the drop out is a very simple layer even
to implement so you have lots of neurons
okay a series of hearings and a drop out
requires you to specify an a probability
a rate of dropping out that memory and
after that you basically put the zero
the value of the neuron and so you
basically are cut the connection between
the white and that numeral okay that's
the idea of the dropout and the the
rationale behind it that you want to add
our variability to your data and so to
avoid overfitting most of the time in
fact for that reason the dropout is a
layer that you have to use only in the
training phase not on your tests are in
the inference phase and this particular
feature is provided for you
automatically by carers for instance so
if you take a look at the our dropout
code okay from the Charis code okay this
is the implementation of the dropout
layer if you scroll down the code okay
you will see that there is this function
here okay dots in train face actually
are our friends went away but this is I
the one who asked me about the the
advantages of the back end but this is
the case of the implementation of our
drop of layer okay as you can see inside
this code Chara's is using the careth
back end code okay and this is because
you may have a dropout function on both
piano and tensorflow
so depending on the back end you
this function is automatically
translated to the corresponding function
on the real back-end and there is this
function here which is the in train face
which is the function controlling that
you're actually during the training face
you are not choose a training face this
layer is automatically are discarded not
considered the I have to actually note
here the one is please note where the K
dot in train face is actually called I
mean where in terms of Python and this
function is the call function okay this
gives you the intuition that each layer
in a Karass object in a Karass code is a
callable object okay this I will make
more sense very soon but please keep
these in mind the Charis layers are
callable objects okay so if you know a
bit of colourful objects in python you
will see what I mean and then you should
take a look at what the Charis in train
face function is this function from the
documentation selects X in the training
face and alt otherwise so know that all
should have the same shape as X so
actually it's a function that provides
you to research used apps our tensor in
face which is not the learning face okay
so the this exercise is just to just ask
you to add the droplet layer on the
previous models and see if that makes
any difference to the performances to be
very simple problem and actually does so
again I forgot to remove the solution so
this is it on so basically you have the
dense layer and then the drop out before
the other dense layer okay so the idea
is I I probably forgot to mention that
the only mostly used parameter for the
drop out layer is the first
which is right and I just I'm just
mentioning it because depending on the
frame of you using I I think cafe
probably has a different interpretation
of the drop last layer in Karis the
parameter the rate parameter is a
floating number of course between 0 and
1 and extracts the fraction of the
dropping okay so the probability of
dropping that neuron in some other
frameworks that parameter could be the
probability of retaining the neuron okay
that's why I'm putting your tension
height in Karis is just the dropping
rate okay so the probability you want to
drop the new run in this case we're
dropping the 20% of the numeron okay we
are 2.2 at the rate permeability ah okay
so that's it it's very simple
so we recreate the sequential object
adding this drop out layer and if we
plug it and we just increase by 2 the
number of you box you will see that the
performances increases definitely and
moreover the number of parameters have
been reduced by the drop out of course
because we have less connection than
before okay and so as you can see the
training the loss function and the
accuracy has have two different
behaviors here okay so it seems to it's
working better okay so if we continue
training at some point the violation
loss will start to increase of course
and that is what is called overfitting
of course it is always necessary to my
two training evaluation data and I was
asking you if you have any clue on how
to do it we actually already so that
trick for it all right
the answer is you can do the early
stopping distance okay that can be a
proper solution to monitor so to plug
the
stop being inside it and so these are
the stopping this quest patient I would
say because it waits until four
different epochs to be equal okay before
you go another thing here we actually
using are the reader function as
previously okay and the reason why these
very simple networks works with these
images is even because of the real
function and so that's it so we actually
plug in so we're actually modifying the
feed model plugging the call back inside
so to reply to a previous question how
you can actually access the tensors
inside the sequential object okay so the
we may rephrase the question by how can
I inspect layers inside network we are
ready so the summary method okay
so we have the summary of the models
okay but the sequential object are these
property which is the layers which is
our unintellible of through the
different layers you have okay and so we
can actually print this information and
we can access directly this information
modulus is still the sequential object
we have the input and output property
that are the input and output tensors
respectively okay so you can have model
dot input if the tensor object okay
which is the very first layer with this
shape when you see these okay as sort of
on note when you see this question mark
here this means that any number you want
okay most of the time in carers and
intensive flow as well this has been are
indicated by a none of the of the very
first parameter and the none in this
particular case means any number you
want so any variable a the first
dimension of that shape of course is the
shape of the samples and that means get
that
dancer works for any number of samples
you have of course okay so we we're not
strict to any specific number of samples
and these sets of features are so we go
through the network configuration okay
and so we see we're actually are
printing the name the this trainable
flag okay the name is the name of the of
the of the layer automatically assigned
but because we did not specify any name
when we define the layers we can do it
at most of time it's quite handy to do
it especially when you want to access
directly a single layer inside the deep
network our this our flag is quite
useful especially when you do when you
want to do something which is called
fine-tuning and transfer learning the
layer dot trainable is a flag that
specifying if that layer is are affected
by learning process okay otherwise it is
automatically skipped during the
learning process so the weights do not
change and then we access the
configuration of layers so basically the
values of all the parameters for that
layer and we are just printing these
information here so another very
interesting property is that most of
time we want to um let's say open the
box so when we are dealing with deep
network specially okay we end up having
series of layers one after the other and
this is especially the case of our
feed-forward convolutional networks
where you are convolutional filters and
fully connected layers just like this
ones and so sometimes you may be are
useful to see what's actually going on
inside the learning process and so
inside layers and so you want to see how
the network is actually seeing the data
inside and this is actually the eye the
code i want to share with you here so on
one way to do it is to on replicate
the piece of network you want to are
basically open okay and I provide to
that network initialize the weights for
that network with the weights of the
original networks up to that layer and
then are call the predict method just to
basically do the forward pass so the
inference but we're not fitting the
model again okay
is that clear the idea was quite simple
okay so I having that previous network
in mind
so the one we drop out we want to see
how the images are looks like how the
image a single image looks like in this
layer here so we create our new network
with these three layers exactly the same
as before then we iterate I call this
model truncated light rate over the
layers of the new model truncated layers
okay and we set the weights to D sorry
we set the weight to these layers using
the layers of the weights of the
original model okay it's quite handy is
quite useful to do its what simple to do
and then we compile this new model okay
so as to cross-check we check that for
instance the weight okay for the first
layer so layer zero is totally equal to
the weight of the layers of the original
model okay and that's true the zero here
is because our get weights basically in
this case returns a couple of arrays or
tensors if you like I one is for the
weight the other one is for bias I'm
just comparing just the weights okay and
so finally I end up predicting the
representation of the layer with these
eden features and so the shape of these
is our 45,000 and that's the are that
the shape of the x train in fact
that's the shape of x-ray so it works
and the number of features is 512 which
is exactly the number of neurons we have
in upward from that layer so seems to be
working so if we want to muscle time if
one to see our proper representation of
these on I features okay
we can one we want to do some sort of
projection of the data in what is called
an embedding layer okay in this
particular case I'm using the TS knee
algorithm you maybe want to try
different algorithms for instance the
multi-dimensional scaling is another one
quite heavily used my experience with
this is that basically I the TS knee
works very well in combination with deep
networks because the tears Diaz me alone
works very well with lots of data when
you are very few data gives me is
basically random guessing okay so
multi-dimensional scaling is definitely
better also time but when you have lots
of samples the GSD is definitely good so
we actually projecting the data we have
in these 512 space into these two
dimensional space because we want to
plot it I'm actually reducing the number
of samples we want to plot for
computational reasons okay and then I'm
doing some actually sir our trickery to
do to create the the arm the plots here
this is what you got basically so the
images you can see that the number one
is quite good classified from that
Network I probably the same case of the
six and and the two here but you have
some problems here with the nine and
seven because probably some handwritten
may looks like are may look like a seven
according to the method of course and
there's a lot of confusion here between
these digits so it's nine it's seven
again no it's not seven
four so it's nine four the five is a
total mess here according to this layer
okay and so I believe these are the most
complicated features to classify one
thing probably wiser to do in the
splitting in your very original
splitting would be to do a stratified
splitting I just applied our trained a
split so it's not very wise in the real
cases who want to do a stratified
folding and maybe even a crossbow
debaters stratified folding but that's
it I actually I provided the bookie
interactive chart as well in case you
want to play with it and so you can
actually I play and zoom inside so doing
this Bakke of course it's very handy and
useful most of time unfortunately there
is no support for 3d in Bakke so you may
end up using different libraries to do
3d but if you have 3d for TF knees quite
an appealing actually and very effective
especially because you're moving between
the images that will be definitely nice
to see okay but this is what you want to
do when this is what you do when you
want to basically open the box and see
what's inside what actually the network
is learning and this is useful to do
especially at different different layers
so you may think of it as a serious off
our probes you put inside the network
and get in so you basically get these in
features for instance of the first layer
and then the third layer for instance
I'm just saying numbers and fifth layer
okay and so you see how the different
data are the data differently
represented inside the metal again
Heights n so how the learning is
changing the presentational features
okay so I I believe I'm we're running
out of time I'm sorry
so it went even worse than my
expectation I'm sorry well so these
exercises here as for the
multi-dimensional scaling asking you to
try a different eye manifold and also to
extract the idiom features of the first
and the last layer so but now you see a
you you know how to do it okay so we
left behind lots of stuff actually but
you will find all the materials in the
eye not books I will be here for the old
conference so our feel free to I'd catch
me catch me up and ask me questions and
a problem
so every eye at glance are you you will
find in examples with convolutional
neural networks and I prefer amateur
tuning and so this is are particularly
useful I went with one you want to do on
hyper parameter indeed carers provides
you on these rapper for the grid search
in psychic learn automatically so you
can use the grid search from psychic
learn insight for carers objects but
indeed there is also are these library
to do that I which is which combines
basically carers and I propped so I
properties the library for I parameter
optimization with a name which is not
actually a cool one I'm saying but I
that's it
and it's quite useful to to use and and
so you also find examples where deep
neural networks and so how carers
provides you automatically the
implementation of very deep networks so
vgg 1619 and residual networks also and
finally some examples with regarding new
networks and autoencoders ok so that's
it thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]